welcome to this video playing a gambit
muffin from Bulgaria right yes I split a
cookie 6 mm maybe can I do something
else I'll play a queen pawn opening just
to have some variety in the games um jam
taking I guess if he takes with the
Queen he might have queen before as a as
an idea so I betterment and prevent that
well let's say I make it yeah I play it
like this doesn't make much sense
anymore okay III and Bishop d3 it's a
very healthy structure that probably
it's not them very advantageous but
still easily playable okay um yeah I
guess III yeah I mean he can play knight
c6 and possibly go 45 aha I came that's
interesting maybe better basics coming
should I play queee too yeah also 95 as
a possibility going for a stone ball
type of setup or Queenie to Queenie too
though he might play just a five jump
okay still it looks like a relatively
usefulness and a five is some
intending Busha basics but other than
that not especially a threatening yeah
and wonders to wonder about 95 Bishop
asics there is no idea maybe I wonder
okay I can't do that move anyway it's
not not bad what I'm wondering is if he
plays Bishop a six and I exchanged as a
term may be an idea to simply put the
Queen on b5 and claiming that I have
some play against the this Queen side it
is slightly weakened like this maybe it
also prevents 97 I don't think that I
actually threatened to take the pawn I
mean there is a probably rupee aid and
my queen is is very unsafe on the green
side maybe I'm threatening to take it ah
ok that's an interesting choice if I
take with the pawn with with a seaport I
mean there is the possibility to play
something to be four maybe even the
Queen now but then I take and play king
e to wear this is slightly better
forward
it is slightly better for why because he
has the queenside already weakened and
my king is in the center so I am I don't
have any problems with getting the King
involved I haven't canceled which is
which is helpful yeah but Luke's is 67 I
was actually intending Roxy one but I
didn't really appreciate that he is
quickly getting the pawn but I get to
see seven now okay I get to see seven if
he takes takes Knight a to Luke c7's
awkward I'm attacking F sub lattices not
defendable with raghav aight of course
of course but I have Roo Roo p7 and get
the pawn back this is what I was
referring to him in he can he can do
that but I'm not sure I'm not sure it is
good yeah this doesn't look too bad I
didn't want to allow knight c6 with the
slow move like a 3 this should probably
just equalize interior of course 96 is
not possible but it's a threat I'm
threatening yes I'm threatening um III
actually and then he needs to retreat I
don't think I have a better move and now
now it's interesting 97 would be great
idea but he has it covered g4 is maybe a
move Taylor but okay Kingy 7g 597 is
probably not not doing so much
yes to let get gain space it's probably
not a bad move now night only six this
is a really bad piece ya mean isn't king
is seven almost first year I don't and
I'm kicking the eight maybe okay so he's
inserting those moves I don't mind to
gain more space on the queenside if you
place gphi this is certainly helpful for
me I can just take it and play em and
play neither three so he allowed me to
tube to play this this thing here is g5
yeah okay it's a space gainer that's
that's clear so um yeah but knight c6 is
not really great I just I just don't
have a good move against King be six so
I wonder Knight f3 or take it may be
taking it is easier even yeah maybe take
it so that Knight f3 9485 is actually
with the check this should be irritating
and you cannot just exchange everything
I think this wouldn't help okay now my
idea is to to use the H file or the G
file to attack this this slightly
weakened pawns okay so we just move the
slide away
time warning okay I try for g7 as the
entry square okay i wants to get the
night 26 which is not not a bad idea but
i'm on those witnesses really
I had to move the King to d3 beef
beforehand to always prevent something
on the sea far looks it too when stuff
now let's that's really a bit annoying
now how does he protect that really I'm
surprised I mean he does not really get
anywhere on the sea fowl I can be able
to maybe I should have gone to do to
actually check prevent rook rook see one
even ah this I forgot it's actually a
pretty good defense okay but I still I
still have some activity
going for a fee for the main problem
here is the time not the position really
check maybe 96 is approaching yeah just
I just played far too slowly here check
check check grah game grounds is a
repetition this is very lucky with one
second on the clock yeah and they're
lost the threat here around here why
does white is just just much better but
I i gave i gave it really away with both
some not not very precise moves it start
with King King be three young yeah we
can check it later King d3 this was
really wrong kinky to as much stronger
if you want to do this just am
preventing moxie one as well and here
yeah he rhymes I'm just feeling I'm just
failing to to play it correctly yeah I
want I didn't see rookie seven at all
which is a shame though the computer
gives look I'm h8 as a good movie em oh
yeah and that's it it's keeping the
pressure on that's the important thing
if you look at this this route GG aid
that this is so this is very problematic
for black
yeah they're so I probably spoiled it
with with them trade and now okay I mean
I can't worry about prime maybe I'm just
too ambitious and still here in this
position and just should just stay put
and hear it it's tricky work of course
with 25 seconds but around here I'm
getting am getting in trouble because he
can he can get this in and then my
default Bonilla is much more of a
problem than st5 porn check yeah yeah
here black is close to close to winning
he's writing this and the chat as well
yeah I spoiled it only I shouldn't trade
rooks really alright thanks for watching